schwarz
die leute ja es ist zehn uhr bis freitag
ich bin in köln
heute finden die video des staates ich
habe gar nicht erläutert was genau
gesagt man muss ich heute auch nicht
weil er weit geht bei mir viel ab und ja
ich habe mir egal ob ich bin halt erst
aufgestanden
ich bin nicht mal auch schon ich bin
wach gebrannt und ich halt mal ein
bisschen mit hab ja ganz lange schon
nicht mehr gemacht und dann gucken wir
mal was so alles passiert die nächsten
tage werden auf jeden fall cool ich war
schon gestern auch nach coolen
veranstaltungen von google und dann auch
noch irgendeiner party keine ahnung wie
ich dahin gekommen wird aber auf jeden
fall cool so jetzt habe ich mich
umgezogen
ich muss mich schon eigentlich ein
bisschen beeilen weil wir haben schon 12
uhr ich sollte eigentlich um 10 uhr
debatte um 11 uhr da sein
auf jeden fall gehe ich jetzt auch meine
freundin abholen die kommt auch noch
hier hin und dann gucken wir mal was wo
abgeht ja wir sind jetzt in der garage
ich habe noch juli mit dabei haben wir
auch noch getroffen
eine freundin gekommen aber die wollte
er wahrscheinlich nicht sehen
ich mache es auf dem blog von peter
games kommt so auf jeden fall auf dem
video days und alex ist so eine
millionen chips auf jeden fall abonniert
main kanal und abonnieren ja weil alex
mein zweiter ehemann ist und dass man
auch offen zeigen und es sei doch rein
gespritzt hatte
die handtasche gut ski fährt
und ja make up und liefert und albers
afrika sagt ja das wollte ich sagen und
wenn ihr noch irgendwas wissen wollt
dann geht einfach auf mein kanal um die
gesagt abonnieren
alle samstag 14
ja klar
kannst du dich richtig ein nein ja aber
ich halte es nicht
ich fand die show wirklich gerade bist
scheiße
ehrlich ich will eigentlich eigentlich
wieder gut aber das was hier gerade
abgeliefert wurde einfach nur
katastrophal schlecht bis auch so die
üblichen die thema auftreten die können
das und das auch gut aber erfahren war
dabei wo ich dachte da können die auch
mich hinstellen ganz ehrlich kann ich
ein bisschen was haben wir noch mal
gemacht was geht ab köln
fragen
ein
age
er geht auch aus
schöne äußern
hallo
naja egal dann gehen wir noch eine runde
trainieren was sicher durch hallo guten
morgen leute was geht ab ja ich muss mir
entschuldigen und zwar bin ich jetzt
aufdecken zu den video da ist schnell
aber heute gehe ich auf jeden fall auch
zur gamescom weil ich hatte ein cooles
ticket bekommen und da muss man ja auch
mal vorbeischauen dann auf jeden fall
ich musste gas auch zum arzt viele
wüssten von euch ich gut operiert und
dann muss ich einmal so alles checken
lassen
und ich hab da so zwei stunden gewartet
deswegen konnte ich heute morgen nicht
zu einem meet greet kommen deswegen mit
richtig leid und alle die da bahn
beim ein bild machen
vom auf
das geht wie mir meine bodyguards
bahnten
hier habe ich nur netterweise zur zur
gamescom alles klar
künzel noch aus weil weiter braucht er
sich nicht alle spielbanken danke
red
ab dem 6 ich darf es nur in die games
convention wenn ich leute hören kurs
youtuber ich muss jetzt den mich weil
ich geh doch mal in ihrem profil einfach
nur tee hna.de rs die im olympia coup da
mal vorbei wenn wir das verstanden haben
jetzt rein
ich liebe dich ich habe
die
ja ja
katja
bmw mid ju blick auf
jawohl
dollar bzw
ich bin jetzt so weit fertig bin gerade
voll am arsch aber es war auf jeden fall
cool
du bist
ein kanal oder
rainer schneider
dann kommt sehr unsympathisch das mit
rein stellt sich jetzt sagen
und warte mal was es ist
nein spart das gar nicht mehr
wenn ihr bisher wenn ihr euch selber
nicht um alex seine videos jetzt lesen
kennenlernen durfte
auf jeden fall heute dürftig
sabine an dem es dann wieder bestens
leute wir haben jetzt heute sonntag und
für mich geht es jetzt auch auf die
gamescom denk ich mal meine freundin
fährt jetzt gleich zum glück was dann
war es auch schon mit dem wochenende in
köln kann ich wieder nach hause und
ordentlich youtube durchziehen
ansonsten ich melde mich gleich wetter
ist irgendwie scheiße heute ist es das
sollte man sofort zu schlechte laune hat
soll den ganzen tag geregnet
frechen kommentaren man heute merkt euch
immer quer über die straße gehen damit
man den längeren weg hat und bis gleich
es war ein langer blog ich hoffe hat
euch gefallen falls ihr das feiert dann
lass mir doch gern mal daumen nach oben
da wir fahren jetzt nach hause und wir
dann erstmal schlafen sind beide
ziemlich müde
ansonst will ich sagen wie gesagt da
nach oben wird mich sehr freuen könnte
auch mal bei raabs vorbeischauen link in
der video beschreibung aber müsst ihr
natürlich weiter spaß dann würde ich
sagen wir sehen uns morgen beim neuen
video
mir ist es noch gelungen ich hab ihn in
köln richtig hart verarscht das kommt
morgen wahrscheinlich online hoffe ich
mal und schönen abend euch noch wir
sehen uns peace haut rein hab ich von
meinen kopf auch mein bein durch mein
fuß in die kamera halten